it is one of the most popular dogs
around and also one of the most hardest
to get
waiting lists can be pretty long to to
adopt a doodle
yeah they are a mixed breed of fluff
that's creating a really big craze
christian koskaris takes a closer look
at all the hype
he is live as a at the desert breeze dog
park
and that is a great way to start
christian
hey guys i want to introduce you to
someone very very special to me
uh let me see if i can grab a better
hold of her here but this is
lucy she is my seven month old golden
doodle
and she is my dog she's my little
princess and she's also the one
responsible for destroying a lot of
things at my house
but let me tell you she is great these
are great dogs and
she's not the only one here actually
we're here at desert park at the dog
park
and as you can see there's so many
people out here with their dogs and let
me tell you it's not just the size and
the color
that makes these dogs so attractable and
so popular but it's also just that
shaggy look that
scruffy look and basically the envy of
so many other dogs
[Music]
they're cute here he goes again smart
and can set you back thousands of
dollars a lot
every six weeks he goes to get groomed
he doesn't like me
brushing him unless i have lots of
treats
they're not cheap and if you do find a
cheap one it's probably not real
doodle dogs have been a growing demand
over the years
they range in size but the affection
they give is never enough
for their humans these snuggles into you
it's not like there's a dog laying on
you my dogs mean the world to me
they're my babies he's like i need to go
over here they come in different colors
and sizes
the most popular reason dog lovers seek
them is for their hair
for me it was the no shedding thing so
once i
started going down that rabbit hole of
what dogs don't shed
it was either like a standard poodle or
some type of doodle
so we just landed on a golden doodle the
mixing of dogs can determine the type of
doodle you get
take a golden retriever and a poodle
that will give you a first generation or
f1 golden doodle
now take that golden doodle combined
with a poodle you get an
f2b and so on actually got him using our
wedding money so
everybody that came to our wedding
helped us get this guy
and now we realize that we don't i don't
think we could ever get another breed
because they are just so much fun
the doodle community is tight on social
media and keeps a tight leash on each
other
that doodle page on facebook and we go
back and forth
tips you know questions we get together
you know a couple times a week and let
the dogs run around it's awesome
all right guys well back out here live
these dogs are sweet and also very high
maintenance but
their healthcare can also be a very very
pricey now coming up on our second part
to the story
i'll talk to you about how effective pet
insurance is and also we're going to be
sharing a very special story about a dog
very close to my family's heart so
hopefully uh you will be able to join us
here on eight news now for now christian
casa does 8 news now
and christian you talked a bit about the
cost the purchase
food all the grooming with that kind of
wild hair at times how difficult can it
be to get one of these dogs
price wise well let me tell you
sometimes we do have the same
hair it's just the gel here that kind of
sets up sets us
apart here um but let me tell you uh
it is very difficult i've been talking
to a couple of folks and they tell me
that sometimes it ranges from anywhere
from three months
to up to years to get one of these dogs
on a personal level i can tell you that
it took us a couple months to get her so
there's definitely a very long
waiting period for them but they are
they are
definitely worth it they are worth it i
may be biased they are absolutely worth
it and by the way
lucy gave you your workout today you
don't need to go to the gym you're
getting your arm work out there trying
to keep her corral
thank you she's heavy yeah she is heavy
and she wants to know what's going on
over there
over there it's fun to look at lucy